[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen im verlief
welt ich bin heute morgen richtig gut
drauf denn ich möchte heute einen
wundervollen leckeren notice zu packen
das ganze ist wirklich keine
produktplatzierung wir lieben einfach
los creme ich glaube die lebt jeder
lotus creme ist das hier lotus kekse
sind die hier die gibt es auch in cafés
gerne mal so klein und abgepackt ich
kenne die auch tatsächlich von der
süßwarenmesse auf dich eigentlich immer
jedes jahr in dieses jahr leider nicht
aber die note screen ist trotzdem ein
fester bestandteil unseres
vorratsschrank ist und heute gibt es
einen leckeren lostopf damit den habe
ich neulich auch zubereitet als von die
kohle zurück war und ich glaube sie
hatte ihn betitelt als
das ganze besteht aus einem hefeteig ich
zeige euch nur kurz die zutaten und das
brauche ich jetzt erstmal nicht es kommt
zur seite steht den hefeteig nämlich
einen halben würfel hefe 80 gramm
braunem zucker 2 esslöffel wasser 400
kamel 200 gramm ein eigelb 80 com weiche
butter und etwa einem dreiviertel
teelöffel salz das eigentlich so main
standard hefeteig heute mit nur 400
gramm mehl weil ich später eine schöne
kastenform nehmen möchte und deswegen
auch bisschen weniger hefe und alles und
weil lotus auch so ein bisschen
caramelle schmeckt nehme ich jetzt hier
einfach braunen zucker stadt weisen zu
tag damit wird es auch wunderbar
funktionieren und dann gebt ihr jetzt
hefe zucker und wasser in die
rührschüssel und können das ganze jahr
verrühren
[Musik]
das ist sogar vegan als ihr könnt auch
tatsächlich einen veganen hefeteig zu
bereiten da gibt es auch schon rezepte
auf einem kanal da könnte das objekt zu
bereiten
wundervoll okay beim hefeteig gibt jetzt
einfach alle zutaten hinein zuerst mail
und dann kommen erst die fertigen sachen
dazu und autos als also das mehl dann
mit die butter und eigelb und deshalb
und dann schön den hefeteig verrühren
beziehungsweise verkneten für etwa zehn
minuten
[Musik]
so sieht der teig jetzt wundervoll aus
jetzt klebt da auch nicht mehr ist schön
geschmeidig und jetzt nehme ich den raus
form ihn zu einer kugel und kann ihn
erstmal aufgehen lassen
[Musik]
hefeteig aufgehen dafür fertig die
schüssel immer gerne mit etwas back
trends bericht legt die kugel schon rein
und fette sie an der oberfläche damit
sie nicht austrocknen und entweder lasst
ihr jetzt den teig abgedeckt bei
zimmertemperatur uhr für eine stunde
ungefähr bis er sich verdoppelt hat oder
zum beispiel bei der stufe im dampf
backofen oder auch ganz gerne in der
küchenmaschine zum waschen in der
kenwood mit hitze funktion einfach schön
bis er sich verdoppelt
ich glaube so lange kann ich schon mal
die förderung zu bereiten für die creme
nehme ich jeweils 80 gramm mandeln und
haselnüsse ein eiweiß 100 gramm lotus
kekse einen teelöffel zimt etwas milch
zu verdünnen zum verstreichen natürlich
die lotus gräben und hier habe ich noch
meine sorte kernel patches ihr könntet
ihr gemahl müsse nehmen und wandeln oder
sie einfach setzte kleidern ich bin echt
entferne form müsse immer selber zu
zerkleinern das macht hier kurz eben
speedway ihr könnt aber auch einen mixer
oder eine gewürzmühle verwenden oder sie
ganz beim packen das dauert aber ein
bisschen nicht
[Musik]
das war mein workout für heute
20 rechts 20 link
bizeps trizeps
alles sitzt
dann könnt ihr jetzt die muss man die
mischung mit dem eiweiss verrühren das
habe ich jetzt übrig weil ich das eigelb
im hefeteig dabei habe dann zimt
dazugeben
und die milch aufgießen
[Musik]
und dann wenn jetzt noch die logistik so
zerkleinert
[Musik]
und die kekse kommt dann auch noch dazu
jetzt ist auch der hefeteig soweit ich
lebe einfach hilfe teig es ist immer
wieder schön
dann kommt hier etwas mehl auf die
arbeitsfläche und ihr könnt den teig
erstmal schön gleichmäßig groß ausrollen
und damit auch wirklich gleichmäßig
funktioniert könnte nämlich einen
ausdruck starb mit abstand nehmen oder
zum beispiel teig hölzer nebendran wegen
und dann ist es auch schön gleichmäßig
[Musik]
ich-form den teig dann immer mit den
händen so ein bisschen rechteckig roldan
nochmal drüber und dann habt immer noch
schöne platte
[Musik]
das war mithilfe
jetzt macht das die mehr
und jetzt kommt der lustige fahrt denn
jetzt nehmt ihr die lotus creme und eure
nuss mischung und das ganze kommt jetzt
hier einfach gefleckt auf die
teigplatten
ja das ist lustig
wenn jetzt hat es ist lustig dann wird
alles
ist mir wichtig
man muss sich nur die positive gedanken
kann man dann kommen die von ganz allein
[Musik]
und dann schön gleichmäßig verstreichen
nicht so gut
und jetzt schön auf rollen und
[Musik]
jetzt nehmt ihr euch schnell kastenform
zum beispiel ihr könnt den zucker war
auch gerne frei auf einem blech backen
sowie meine lust oder eine kastenform
nehmen dann packt den schönen form und
heute darf ich euch unsere neue form
vorstellen das ist nicht unsere baba
form richtig und zwar mir da jetzt
einfach ne gusseisen form gemacht in
eckiger form weil sich ganz viele
zuschauer eben eine echte brot backform
gewünscht haben aber man kann er darin
nicht nur brot backen sondern eben auch
alles garen was man in gusseisen im
garten kann oder im ofen garen kann auf
dem herd zubereiten kann sogar auf dem
grill draußen wirklich für jede herd
geeignet und deswegen mag ich den jetzt
drin dann packt er nämlich schon hoch
und
die fertig vorher ein bisschen mit
bakterien spray
sie könnte aber eine glasform zum
beispiel nehmen falls ihr alle habt oder
wie gesagt komplett ohne backform das
gilt auch jetzt
hier mit ich einschneiden und ich
schneide denen nicht immer komplett
einmal durch weil mir dann der zopf
einfach auseinander fällt das heißt die
eine hälfte bleibt noch zusammen damit
ich erstmal hier flechten kann dann
drehe ich es um und vielleicht die
andere hälfte dann ist es ein bisschen
einfacher jetzt beide stränge in die
hand nehmen und einfach um ein anders
werden
und am ende verknotet ist immer so ein
bisschen
und schiebt dann da unten durch
[Musik]
und wenn ihr den job jetzt frei auf
einem blech packt dann ist es so dass es
sich praktisch in alle himmelsrichtungen
vergrößert und ausgepfiffen
also der wird halt breit und lang und
wenn ihr den hier in der form bakhtov
jetzt gusseisen frau oder eine kerze
dann wächst
stell dir vor
dass die einstiegs in die wachsende
finde ich das okay
schön und
hier gebe ich jetzt den deckel drauf
wenn jetzt eine backform habt mit deckel
dann ist es so wie beim brotbacken wenn
ihr auch im greisen backt und zwar tritt
jetzt die feuchtigkeit also die
flüssigkeit aus dem teig aus geht nach
oben sammelt sich hier am deckel dann
sind hier diesen locken da kondensiert
das wasser und tropft wieder runter und
es sorgt dafür dass man eben einen
hefezopf wie unter dampf backen kann
also als hätte man den backofen ihr
können und sich auch dampf einschalten
bei hefezöpfe oder hefeteig allgemein
und dann wird er einfach saftiger die
kruste wird schön es geht einfach besser
und ich werde die erste zeit im backofen
den deckel drauf lassen und dann kurz
vor einer decke runter nehmen und ich
stelle sie den kalten ofen das heißt ich
brauche den hefezopf nicht mehr aufgehen
lassen sondern der kalten ofen erledigt
das ich halte ihn jetzt auf 180 grad
ungefähr und ich denke nach ungefähr 30
35 minuten nämlich den decke runter und
sprach den job schon fertig
oh nein
eigentlich als letztes mal schon
vergessen ich habe es gerne mal
vergessen
wie kann es sein das kann man vergessen
augen
[Musik]
bis jetzt einfach drauf gestreut
dieser bitte vergesst das gibt's doch
nicht
ich habe das extra abgewogen und dahin
also eigentlich gehört das über die
teigplatten und der rest wird gegessen
deswegen keinen zucker in die massen
egal ob und weniger zucker
[Musik]
sie verlaufen mal rein wegen der schwere
der tat steht
mal anbietet
ja
sieht man das nicht hallo
berlin 25 jahren
hallo herzlich willkommen dies meldet
wie er wirft haben wir einen hefezopf
gebacken und da ist jetzt die halbe zeit
um und wir nehmen den deckel ab ganz
klar damit das schön goldgelb wird 8 uhr
und kurz wieder rein und wieder an
derselben stelle raus
ja der große augenblick
machen
der große augenblick
hahaha
sollte karl ecker super lecker
jetzt kriegt dann nochmal wärme noch mal
vize damit er schön goldgelb wird 20
minuten bei
180 grad
perfekt
hallo herzlich willkommen weiß dies
meldet wie er wüst habe mir einen
hefezopf gebacken und da es sitzt die
halbe zeit um und wir nehmen den deckel
auf ganz klar damit das schön goldgelb
wird
[Musik]
der große augenblick
hh
jetzt kriegt dann nochmal wer mehr noch
mal vize damit er schön goldgelb wird 20
minuten bei
180°
wenn der zopf dann fertig gebacken ist
die das so aus mutter muss ich sagen es
wundervoll hat es gemacht ganz toll ich
war kamera kind ich hoffe er findet
meine aufnahmen auch toll dass wir sehr
mühselig muss ich sagen so anstrengend
ob gut und wenn dazu fertig ist dann
erstmal raus stützen
und ein wenig abkühlen lassen
und dann kann ich nämlich noch lotus
creme nehmen und ein bisschen erwärmen
es können jetzt in der mikrowelle machen
oder kurz auf dem herd
[Musik]
jetzt lasst ihr einfach die leckere
warme lotus creme über den kopf laufen
und bestreut einfach mit ein paar so
dass kermani wollt oder kick
[Musik]
der job ist fertig und jutta profijt
[Applaus]
der klubs und den perfekten teil noch
weiter gesteigert ich hab das ehrlich
intuitiv gefühl dass
[Gelächter]
die ware sehr gutes kaka amara kind ja
machen neue der hammer ich
[Gelächter]
na ja
das steht ja ich glaube wir haben ein
bisschen beneidet jetzt vom ganzen team
dass du jetzt hier probiert hätte ich
das
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
einfach draußen
das mit
ja und ich hilfe koffer
ich muss echt sagen luftig
wenn man hefegebäck mit dampf
schlosspark wird einfach saftiger kommen
oder halt immer geschlossen
so wie mir macht das ist mal mit dem
topf mit dem bh und barbara
der papa und mama
irgendwann mal englischen taxis generale
mehr oben war von samira und
energie
steht aber vor damit ab sagt finde auch
gerne ohne backen
aber ich bin so haben einfach ein stück
weiter geht das noch mal schön
aufgefunden wunderschön geld ich gut
was ich das so an yahoo
carol mit rufen jetzt noch drin wäre ja
jetzt kommt jetzt
vergessen aber drauf schmeckt auch ganz
ohne reserve dürfte sich nun ist das
highlight wenn man neue weil ich auch
als muss auch das lotus creme angeht da
gibt es einfach kein limit an rezepten
das kann man halt irgendwie immer machen
da geht es los cheesecake mehr als worte
falls euch noch was fehlt in meiner
rezept welt was mit lotus zu tun hat
dann schreibt sie mir ganz gerne oder
fall so jemanden gibt da noch das gar
nicht mag net melden bitte und alle look
at what you're so
viel spaß beim backofenfest findet ihr
wie immer in meiner app oder aufs tennis
- blog.de bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]